big thanks to Shopify for sponsoring
this video more on them after the
reaction alone ladies and gentlemen it
is time for Doctor Who special part do
today John how are you I am in a meta
crisis over how excited I am but I let
it
go I'm not sharp enough we just did a
live stream all righty guys well hey
first things first thank you to all who
have joined us here at real Rejects and
who watched our reaction of part one
that is up here on the channel of of
course uh please go ahead leave a like
on this video that really helps us out
in the algorithm be sure to subscribe
click the notification Bell to get
notified when our reaction for part
three is up here on the Chanel want to
give a heads up to all who have
supported us by get some RR merch ww.
regation shop.com we have a doctor who
shirt that we've been working hard at
that I've had in mind for such a long
time it is looking great but I wanted to
print it out first and make sure that it
fits right hopefully if it turns out
good and I think it's going to turn out
good good you're going to really love it
it's sure have had in mind for a very
long time also Eric Nur chronic thank
you for editing on these highlights for
us buddy you're an excellent editor you
can also check out his work over at
passion fruit a website that goes to
help support many a reactor I've done an
interview there myself that's a
fantastic site and he is uh an important
part of that puzzle there lastly massive
thank you to all who have joined us at
our patreon page that's where you can
catch the full length Reaction watch
alongs for Doctor Who and uh we cover
several shows over there exclusively
with highlights and watch alongs
included in case missed the memo from
last episode that one of our first
patreon shows was Doctor Who and then we
uh finished it and then a few months
went by and and of nothing no Doctor Who
and now we're here so yeah all of our
Doctor Who reactions are over there but
we are continuing here on YouTube anyhoo
let's finally watch
[Music]
this
666 is a glorious day sir what a lovely
day
is this a famous historical
character Adam just had a rush of
thought and ideas whoa damn that a cool
shot sorry we're just slightly out of
control that's a fun shot he could you
tell me what year this is It's 1666 oh
stay away from
London you got a VOC Cod around that
thing hisorical not yet spoilers
spoilers spoilers we got another line
you can
appreciate come come on the gravity of
the
situation the gra what people are going
to get mad about Isaac Newton's casting
whatever sh
hav Hagerty
M they're going to ruin all of history
everyone's going to call it mavity now
are people already on Twitter people are
on Twitter right now about Isaac
Newton's casting woke I knew him isn't
what he was like you ruin history I
can't enjoy reading my history book
anymore I hated
Hamilton oh yeah damn these Tardis
effects in the sound design they are
slapping
wowe Tardis like pering what's on is
there a dragon in there is it changing
the inside again it was brand new sorry
not your fault if it was I mean it's not
a very reliable Tardis if a coffee
spill it's got a sensitive tummy all
right a nor Sonic Screwdriver that's an
homage to the fact that the original
Sonic Screwdriver was just a screw a
screwdriver yeah it's crazy am I going
mad or did the Tes play wide blue y they
did we'd have a little concert every
Christmas but gr's complaint W it's the
military going to war
yeah yeah wild blue young there's a
war's coming
[Music]
rebuild nice there you go mending
mending mending the Sonic Screwdriver
can't just do whatever the script
requires it to do I don't buy it g
there's got to be some solid rules and
lore
wow
nice big very big that's what she said
we just
landed by accident AR that
okay dread we've got air we've got
lights we've got mavity did she just say
mavi just said mavity was it me or was
Isaac Newton hot he Wasing he was hot
that I now panexual
doctor oh
good it's a rogue Tardis episode doctor
you can get the Tardis back can't use
the Sonic the Sonic is in the T it's
your fault I said let's stay here but
you had to wander with you wandered with
me oh like I could stop you you spill C
you just got
reacquainted oh my God where are we
no
a Dr Donna a mechanism on B the Tardis
called the hats hostile action
displacement system the Tardis is in
danger
okay yeah the defaults are back
H yeah War that's why they were playing
the song we go and kick it
ass let's go Donna this is B Mrs be head
of the chir a she said it's not Warsaw
it's Jolly ashes ashes We All Fall Down
you know for kids
is it really riding itself what's going
on here if I'm
right Jehovah starts with an eye who's
this right there you better remember
which one of these big hydraulic arms
you partner you got this next to you're
getting lost oh it's a
robot it's like hitchhiker guide a
little bit I like this
design
whoa time moves in incredibly slow for
this robot maybe time slowed down no I
feel it Inon In Me Bon on MH onward
Z as idiots say e she is just tearing
down my doctor emasculating
him it's like an aquarium we've got a
chair it's a good sign it's a life form
with a bum
space is a
chair someone opened an airlock door 3
years ago that was them dude and then it
closed three years have passed for them
if I'm wrong keep it in the
reaction
dang that's a fierce drone baby Disney
budget H getting Vibes of Oblivion which
is very derivative of a bunch of other
Sci-Fi movies yes it is
where are the stars it could be inside a
dust cloud or a MAV well or M he call it
m intentionally the Taurus was out of
control it's taking us to the edge of
the universe yes yeah
buddy looks boring out there there's
nothing to hear nothing to see if the
universe is everything and the concept
of an everything having an edge is kind
of impossible but that's the language of
21st centur treath and you don't have
anything
yet nothing but the nothing edge of
creation but calling it The nothing
makes it a something if we flew in that
direction it would take 100 trillion
years to reach your house well we better
get going I've never been this far never
been this far damn dude on the
end spooky no
that
whatever except whoever went out that
air
lock oh
yeah
Jimbo they're in like some crazy time
dilation a countdown or instructions
yeah there's a wide variety of things
it's cool to get a Russell T dav's
intense dread episode yeah bottle is
that stuff dangerous
no I don't think
so touch it eat
it it's a joke it's a joke
yeah don't leave me on my own Donna
there is no one else on board this ship
style action remember oh my God they
dumbed down our doctor he's an idiot now
God what a s I hate Twitter
cold air ghosts did it just get cold I
think so I wonder how long they'll way
Rose will grow up she'll have her
life not sure
that he'll keep going back every single
day I hope you get to know him I hope so
too do you think when the doctor gets to
know Shawn that's why he becomes a black
doctor yeah this one experience of a
huge impression on me let me tell you it
didn't happen with any of my other black
friends you Sean let me tell you do you
miss H game I mean yes but not so much
the people they were wankers my arms are
too long
yeah
wow oh we get
hungry what is happening strange the
system should be swimming right out
those rectangles did you move all of
them up my arms are too long ah
whoa my arm's too long
look weird whatever this is we
can that's so
[Music]
strange
oh oh oh my God but the arms are so very
difficult it's an AI oh it's arms are so
very difficult so it's trying to adapt
and I can never figure out hands trying
to replicate
it oh that is so strange I love it
yeah it's like that Ludicrous video
because once I sort out the
arms oh my God we're getting a preview
Disney's M
fantastic my
God it's the knees two in total or two
on each leg what oh where you come from
wow the ostrich legs we are not things
but you we are not things matters oh I
think you'll find work by something nice
you
are what oh my e oh it's like every
thumbnail like a pitch meating
yeah
whoa who oh that that is so
fun oh my God look at her
teeth
oh Jesus so wacky I [__] love it so
much oh boy that sneaks
bro
whoa oh my God this is disturbing no
concept of shape or size they don't
understand matter Sean used to complain
about that watching Venom films he said
where's the extra mask come
from Venom she mentioned galif fry yeah
the doctor said we so then got our
memories memories are mass but what I
don't get is why do they hate
us that's a fair
question my God
bra yo this episode is so wacky I love
it like it's so surreal and strange yet
it's like it's as hell yeah yeah totally
it's like a wacky version of
midnight it is like Supernatural when
there's a ghost nearby the the cold air
is like a Telltale
sign I don't know they real you
yeah look on me I swear I'm really
really me that's not going to
work we need a thing test now but look I
can't stretch my arm is not too long I'm
I'm trying oh [__] it's happening on
both of them yeah they might have a
different perception of surface skin and
clothes might be the same thing so if we
need another doctor with his tie that's
not me you're just making all this up I
always do you were born in chy strange
fact I was born in
sou yeah but I didn't know that cuz I
never
[Music]
did so where are you from no but we've
done that we talked about that all four
of us know it's G C FR it's
not
what what do you mean cuz you're the
Timeless child we are committed to this
piece of lur I've had 15 years without
you and I saw everything that's happened
to you since and oh my God it hurt oh is
this real this is good [__] man in your
head I don't
know the flux yeah it destroyed half the
universe because of me
we stand here now on the edge of
creation a creation which I devastated
so yes I keep running of course I do how
am I supposed to look back on that it
wasn't either way this conversation is
important I fluxed up oh yes I missed
you no no no
yeah oh the knees they had me we that
universe so far away you have owned it
you are such a prize oh my God I'm
definitely Don where's your
time is it yeah oh she's so smart oh I
see you absorbed it back something is
going and keeps
[Music]
existing why does
he as oh my
God doctor
exorcism I don't know which one to shoot
I know you're a fake and know for a fact
so I want to know why you're doing this
that's what I was going to say well you
should have been faster cuz that's me
isn't it fast am I fast do I talk fast
oh well I can't follow any of this and
that is
proof you think you're stupid of course
I do that's so Donna that's my Don
except Donna is there Don does not think
she's
stupid she thinks she's brilliant she
thinks both oh this is a deconstruction
of the characters too they can believe
two completely different things at
exactly the same time people from our
planet yeah it's a
test
God oh my God rain box Earth girl this
is like
superal come on stop copying and make
your own minds up where do to get the
salt she's good at
math it didn't get cold this time no it
didn't did it which means you're
climatizing that was the word I was
thinking vocab you drifted here in the
lack of light your noisy boiling
Universe well I'm sorry and what made
you so bad it's like the thing felt they
shaped us the no we trained them did you
hear what I said the no thing that's
brilliant what I said it's great I love
it they made us like this we are more
than that love letters don't travel very
F I have eaten all the salt I love
salt
stuned revolving
wall
classic why why they making this soate
if they want to copy us why don't they
just sit in a corner and do it what
Terror they need responses yes they have
to learn that's how it's done they
absorb more scared we are than all the
blood pumps hypothalamus adrenaline we
think faster and faster and faster
you're reading us is that right but
you're adapting the worst qualities stop
thinking yes for me what about you you
guys need to start
meditating if we're slow they can't read
us they're really great at playing the
two different roles both of them are man
totally how can you not think on a ship
full of questions why the empty chair
why do the walls keep moving what are
the words in the air and why did the air
lock open and close three years AG stop
it stay yeah come on stop
thinking come on
Doc oh think think think think
think oh my poor guy
guy oh some type of futuristic astronaut
thingy Bojack space horse why is the
captain outside why is she in a space
suit with no helmet oh great she what
the hell ruin everything Doctor Who the
door 3 years ago that wasn't them coming
in that was her going out
right
uh maximized autonomic brain function oh
well done Captain if you copied her
perfect you could you should have thrown
the ship home and started your War yes
yes when she died you hadn't completed
her what is that that's her safety
protocol or
something oh snap so the ship is slow
the robot is slow the words are slow is
that it
nope to become a very slow
what no the unity so the words are a
very
slow
countdown and that's why the Tardis left
cuz this is big old
threat what number are we on fle all
those
dials I don't know what they're touching
but it it looks frantic and
intense stop that robot the robot just
wait this is a really well edited
episode
yeah
Jesus and teeth though yes Donna fight
oh this is
terapeutic yes it
is come on hit sher's guide robot hold
off one more second great
music no no no no
Wolf Man doctor if he runs out of time
the Hostile action ends and a time
machine would
know yes
yes no look wild blue yonder more like
wild blue Wonder climbing High into the
sun leave Donna
behind push off stack to the Future he's
goofy
footed
which one's one which one's which why is
Mrs Bean funny because it's the name of
a vegetable given to a woman is it
it that one yeah
yeah and also cuz of Mr Bean doctor come
back she's not me I'm
me oh
Christ
no no they're not going to
oh my God is this really
happening no he's got to tackle
it
[Music]
no oh my God what the [__]
happening no no
way
no he
knows whoa hey that's
handy oh my God I was like this show is
going to piss me off
yeah
yeah woo oh boy
that
was a yeah captain my
captain how is it how man I know we
still got a couple minutes left that's a
great episode man Jesus Christ holy crap
that my kind of Doctor Who right there
oh I keep thinking I wish I hadn't done
that thing with ass salt what thing I
invoked a
Superstition at the edge of the universe
oh no where the walls are thin and all
things are possible okay you just
created vampires feeling of
something which is gone fine good onward
Which
F Where Have You Been say h s there's
too many episodes of Television Don
robots chases
waterfalls robots chases waterfalls
where are they where's the
[Music]
family
oh my
God how did we did I miss
something
will Wilfred M my dude wilred
M now I feel better now nothing is wrong
I never thought I see you again after
all these years I need to need to put
this together I never lost faith I said
he won't let us down who come back back
and save us save us from what Neil
Patrick
Harris there are big robot oh well those
were there before they're all going mad
listen you're going to do something
doctor it's the
crazies oh my
God what a nightmare what a
nightmare sweet sauce boom
shakalaka Shaka man
that was uh can't I am so excited to
talk about this episode as am I I'm so
excited to talk about it sometimes
keeping track of all this stuff though
yeah feel like feel like building a a
certain site you know what I don't the
way I'm saying this we have a great
sponsor who I already use for our merch
site so take a look thank you for
sponsoring this video thank you to
Shopify for sponsoring which is what we
use for our merch store and is our
gamechanging partner and EC Commerce so
whether you're launching a passion
project or scaling to new heights
Shopify as the e-commerce Powerhouse
guiding you at every step from creating
your first online store to opening
physical locations Shopify makes it
seamless it's perfect whether you're
selling exclusive merch or unique
Collectibles thanks to their
all-encompassing platform for both
online and inore sales their checkout
system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors into buyers than
other platforms and let's not forget
Shopify magic the AI tool that elevates
your business with minimal effort but
seriously reflecting on your journey
using Shopify for www. reation shop.com
it's been transformative the transition
smooth growth exponential thank you
again reject Nation from simplifying
sales to scaling our offerings Shopify
has been a Cornerstone of our success
and Shopify isn't just for us it Powers
10% of us e-commerce backing businesses
big and small in over 175 countries
their awardwinning support always there
to guide you so ready to join the
revolution sign up for Shopify at only a
dollar a month at shopify.com
rejects all lowercase shopify.com
rejects start your Shopify success story
now let's grow together with Shopify
Team all right let's talk about it thank
you Shopify all righty whoa okay now I
am running late for my nephew's birthday
it started an hour ago but I had to
cover this um but John uh what did you
think I love this I mean this is uh I
remember David Tenant describing this as
like or RTD Unleashed and uh and yeah I
mean I I certainly think that this kind
of lives up to that in a way I wasn't I
wasn't exactly sure what to expect but I
love that we got this bottle and this uh
you know sort of quirky demented tension
filled peace you know that I like when
these episodes uh will throw you into
something and yeah it's got you know a
lot of the madness that you want from a
doctor who but you know especially in
the first half you're just kind of
wandering around this big space
wondering what's going on and observing
and soaking in their Dynamic and then
you know bringing in the nothingness
after that and confronting yeah just a
an
existential uh like an existential
threat that also poses all these
existential questions you know about
what's out Beyond the Edge of the
universe and and there's so much about
like holding two conflicting ideas in
mind at once uh yeah I thought this was
really rich and really lovely yeah man
uh okay so I looked it up while you were
talking and Bernard cribbons who does
play wiol he passed away in July of 2022
but they did manage to actually film
this fake I looked it up during the ad
as well and yeah there set photos of
David Tennant Wheeling Bernard cribbons
around and and I guess great they
managed to get that final appearance
it's amazing somehow we managed not to
have that spoiled or see any images of
that until now but yeah I guess they
shot all of his scenes before July of
2022 I had no clue yeah me neither I
thought they were just keeping his
like that was that wow I wonder if they
did any re-shoot to elevate some of that
conversation about him I'm curious I
don't know I have no idea because that
that was so surprising to me I I did not
that was the last thing I expected and
it's Gott me thinking in two two
separate thoughts which is one I am so
happy I had no idea because that was
like a heart swell of a moment at the
same time now I'm I'm kind of not happy
that they showed us NPH in the trailers
because I know that he's going to be on
the horizon and he hasn't shown up yet
so I just assume that he's got some kind
of big involvement in all of this but
maybe he'll just be like the monster so
you don't know what character he's
playing well we know what he's called
yeah it's a classic Doctor Who character
yeah and so you know I I feel like that
might have been a nice surprise then to
have but I get why you need to Hype up
having neop Patrick Harris I'm sorry
John you should sorry for marketing I'm
sorry that they're teing plus trying to
get some subscribers yeah of course I'm
sorry sure uhhuh no jeez we should
really just like show the whole movie in
the marketing movie this is basically
like a small movie is it it wouldn't
flow really well every movie should be
shown in the i' be like the first 45
minutes is very conflictingly different
with the next 45 minutes sure yeah yeah
um but put it all in the trailer no
surprises well I think with h part one
uh being more of that fun Whimsical side
of Doctor Who CU because Doctor Who has
such a variety of tones and genres
and I don't know we really liked the
part one and we saw there was a big
divide and discourse over some stuff
that went down which I do I have no
interest in really diving into right now
uh but I did see there was a divide
amongst that what I would like to take
away from it though is that the first
one was so fun and this is also fun but
in a very different kind of way this
side of Doctor Who that I love like two
of my favorite episodes of Doctor Who do
come from the tenant uh era which
are midnight and blink and I feel like
that's not an unpopular opinion but wow
deep Cuts G I mean midnight more than
blink but you know yeah no those are two
of my absolute favorite Doctor Who
episodes and those episodes are more
serious than this one those episodes are
way more heavy than than this one
however I kind of just expect them they
still carry on that same kind of flavor
from what we got with part one into this
considering that this special is
advertised one gigantic story and what
we got here with telling an isolated
tale at the edge of the universe that
that that it's it's neat to get
something that could feel like abstract
and in a way that still is adherent to
rules when you can kind of be like we
don't have any rules we can do whatever
we want and they were they had C blanch
to kind of do whatever they wanted and
yet they managed to still find a way to
ground it in something that felt
tangible and believable for the world of
Doctor Who that managed to be very
character driven like these are my my
favorite kind of psychological suspense
body horror types of Thrillers that are
so about what's internally going on with
the characters you know like the Mind
Games of I really don't know who's who
in the room I really don't know which
one to believe like the way they they
dealt with the first cutting around
between rooms almost when they were
saying like my arms are too long I was
like why are we watch I was like why are
we cutting between these two scenes like
this this is like so strange that we're
doing this weird inner cutting because
normally inner cutting I is yeah it
happens between two scenes that are
taking place at the same time but they
seem like they were taking place in two
completely different times but within
this same Realms I'm like are we
watching that threeyear Gap that they're
talking about like what it was really it
was immediately disorienting and messing
with the head that you could tell was
building up to something and then when
it finally started showing us what was
going on with the strangeness uh for
lack of a better word for the crazy
amount of like gigantic to stretchy to
uh all kinds of weird body contortion uh
types of visuals I thought was excellent
and very effective and the effects look
great like Doctor Who's kind of known
for you know it's cheesy effects and I
think the effects are more Amplified and
but the best thing about Doctor Who is
that if you have cheesy effects you can
kind of get away with that CU that's
part of the charm of Doctor Who and it's
had like a cool blend of it but more
importantly than that it was like the
the aura of the episode the whole tone
of it and getting into the classic Bill
where the doctor's figuring it out but
it can't really figure it out and it's
like a deconstruction of our characters
and the way these
two they're in the same outfits and
they're they're playing two different
versions of themselves you know yet
instantly distinguishable performances
you know and I thought both um Tom
distinguishable what's her name again
who plays who plays what's her name
Catherine Tate Katherine Tate yeah
Katherine Tate yeah with Katherine Tate
and tennet the two of them uh being able
to play these roles uh to maximum effort
it was it was awesome it it was it was
just so awesome to see them demonstrate
their range and Rhythm and just a great
understanding of it and again just
beautifully edited and taught I I loved
it I I absolutely like this is my
favorite kind of Doctor Who right here
uh I loved it CU it was intense it had
my mind the the wheels were turning and
it you're just you're just on the on the
you're not you're keeping up with the
game but you're not ahead of the game
you know like this was a fantastic
episode uh I really really really love
this episode and for whoever was
dismayed or was like Dr R lost its touch
and whoever's going to make videos about
Isaac Newton not looking like how we
know Isaac Newton to look like whatever
it's 5 Seconds just let
it realiz Newton still exists on the
timeline as he was it's fine who gives a
[__] like what we got here the vast
majority of the episode is so goddamn
rewarding on every front
yeah agree John my music sorry if I
wasn't to rush for the bir trying to a
quality eff fishing Tru terrific I agree
with everything you said uh I wonder if
we'll ever come back to Isaac Newton
because they do say mavity twice and it
does seem like they cheekily uh kind of
blurred the line between that being a a
genuine phenomenon and that being a
reference you know what I realize about
the complimentary side of it before I
forget sorry I I had to have to
interrupt you because I'm going to
forget I know I will you um I'm I see
the thought leaving my brain you should
say it as I'm caught up in the
apologetic side of my
talk before it goes away entirely is
that Isaac Newton it was um he's not the
he's not like the Creator of science um
but he is one of the faces of he helped
Shine the Light so that we could all
come and look at it so it is kind of
cool to go to like the beginning of
science to the edge of the universe you
know in one episode it's pretty neat and
to start off with like the brightest and
beautiful and historical to the darkest
side of the universe that was a great
fake out cuz you get yeah the prospect
of oh cool like my immediate thought
opening up the episode was oh neat we're
going to go into the past and do one of
those historical figure episodes and
then we switch gears into yeah a one of
the more tense and sort of strange
existential cerebral bottle episodes and
I yeah I love that even just the
cheekiness with which they are laying
out the form this time around and
clearly acknowledging the ear marks that
we love from the past but also you know
continuing to push forward using and
really like justifying the choice to
bring back this doctor's face plus uh
Donna again and I'm also curious this
was [__] phenomenal it is just a
Showcase of Russell T Davies and uh I
don't know if he directed it but a
different guy uh it was just a Showcase
of when Doctor Who was firing on all
Cinders for me and and you know what the
like oh they're bringing back Donna
They're bringing back uh the tent doctor
Oh yay and this is the episode that
really gave me that like I like I like
the last episode I had so much fun with
the last episode but this was the one
where I'm like
yes we are
utilizing all of that and it doesn't
have to be this thing where you're
traveling traversing the universe or
something just watch them do their work
watch these performers go to town yeah
and I like that that these specials are
like it's obviously a joy special yeah
100% like it's it's a joy to have David
Tenant back but it's also really nice to
have the both of it's about having the
both of them and and using and exploring
and delighting in that Dynamic which I
think is a really nice thing and I
actually really like this format they're
doing right now with this Trio of
specials because it can sort of breathe
we know it's going to be short-lived but
we can do a couple things and I think
really kind of richly pay homage you
know the way you would want to at some
kind of Touchstone anniversary or
whatever it is uh the the other thing
that I'm curious about is is aside from
the mavity bit which seems like it's
just a dangling like maybe people are
just going to be saying that forever
like are they gonna come back in a post
credit scene on episode three and be
like hey Sir Isaac Newton by the way gr
on that word but I'm also curious that
thing he said about um the Superstition
introducing Superstition at the edge of
all of existence where the veil is thin
and clearly something is out there
listening you know I wonder if that's
going to come back or be some kind of
weird Paradox Loop where it's like oh
man we have all these strange
Supernatural occurrences because you
brought the Superstition here and
someone heard it you you know and well I
I think that's the thing that will tie
most in with the with
uh yeah I didn't want to say it in case
fans didn't know oh sorry I'll just go
back and mute that no stays in the video
there's no time all right we can't mute
it yeah time time once these videos cut
they just upload
immediately no time to adjust anything
for nush for NPR uh to come in here yeah
I think that's it's got a of his
character with the very minimal
understanding I have of that character I
just know his name that's all I
know which which is not going to be said
in this review yeah was kind of known to
be like
a like the doc who's
if if if the master is his Joker I guess
that would be his Riddler okay in a way
okay that sounds like fun I'm I'm here
for it I'm down for it I you could tell
me in the comments if I'm wrong about
that compar I don't even know if youall
the do the Master's Joker I mean that's
what's what I would like doct even
Batman you know like who would be maybe
he's Commissioner Gordon or somebody
else you know yeah yeah yeah um and uh I
thought the music is also too was
excellent it had a a throwback vibe to
it but you could what I love is that it
feels exceptionally composed for every
single scene to
a a a wide range of emotions per scene
you know cuz you got to keep it fun but
you got to keep it scary at the same
time I I could not believe I was in awe
of this one I stuff about why scare us
and and they got to make us move faster
and it's all about being slow and and
watching them try not to think as they
figure each other out like that so much
so much great uh Rich work and also too
carry on the binary theme in a lot of
ways but when it comes to you can have
two emotions and two thoughts about the
same thing and it's and it's a
non-binary then because it's not yeah
it's not one or the other it can be both
or it can be more than just those two
things MH and uh and I had another thing
to say but it's not here any longer so a
nothing it was a no I have no no that's
what they were doing they were doing the
no thing I know it's very clever that's
genius very genius the no thing meets
the no fly or whatever yeah and the Fly
I feel like there's another main
Touchstone here that we're missing yeah
and I'm trying to find it I mean we
talked about wil which was lovely I was
super excited and happy and Overjoyed I
liked I mean I thought it was really
lovely and interesting that they had
just this equin pilot you know who set
all this in motion it's like you have
this character who's not a character but
who still has a presence once
established uh and I would love to see
you know these Bojack horse people in
the future yeah um but yeah I don't know
the the whole idea of nothing and and
yeah the Paradox of like what's
beyond everything you know or or what
happens at the end of everything I think
is like a really lovely you know thing
to dive into especially in a doctor who
environment that's the kind of
paradoxical thing I think that thrives
very nicely here and uh and I don't know
just yeah all the design choices and
stuff like that and like it looked it's
like it looks strange and unsettling
because obviously it's uncanny and its
body horror but also like some of the
effects on those arms and stuff looked
really good
um yeah just uh this whole thing was a
lovely lovely fun experiment usually
when they go to like the end of time in
some capacity that's usually some like
vacant landscape of [__] right and and I
I I find this one to be probably the
most I can't unless I'm totally bling on
one well instead of like a sand dune
somewhere yeah you're just floating out
in the Blackness well there's also that
two parter and the one that felt like
they were going into hell yeah um that
was that was a rose Ty one if I'm not
mistaken what was that one there was
another end of something it's not the
Satan pit one is it I think it was the
Satan pit one the orange when we got the
suit for the first time yeah uh but that
that episode is again that's more of
what I associate when we're going to
like the end of time on something like
this still felt Lively yeah yeah and
it's a it was a fun I I think there's
also that motif of there episodes where
like the Tardis takes off and is gone
and we're stranded and we're this time
without the Sonic also that's was cool
cuz he just had to rely on his brain
yeah yeah just had to rely on the
intellect and even when it comes back at
the end that whole thing about like a
time machine would know like I I thought
that was a nice brilliant structure
great structure a nice way to have you
know it just in the nick of time but
also not be too much of a Deus exmachina
or anything like that still have the
turnaround of the Mr Bean thing with
Donna him taking on the wrong Donna I
thought for a minute I was like they
might kill her I I might be upset with
they do but yeah I would have been
really upset I would have been like no I
don't care how great this episode is you
haven't quite earned this moment just
yet yeah yeah yeah yeah and so for for
what it I mean and and and I guess if
there's anything you could have expanded
maybe a little further it's the very end
of the episode so I'm not griping about
this whatsoever but you know the
Salvation you could have stretched that
a little longer to be like oh damn she's
gonna die you know um but you know once
they cut back into the Tardis when you
think she's a goner you're like ah no
here it comes but I I have the show had
me too like I I was wrong so much at the
time when when he chose the wrong one I
was like no that's the right one well
that's yeah and and they're good at
choosing when they're really obviously
not the right one and when they are very
close to being and that whole thing
about like they're they're not 100%
solidified yet and so they go kind of
back and forth as they home in on you
know the fullon likeness and all that
stuff and yeah then it gets you
wondering like what would happen if he
did return with like this nothing Donna
although that then would a be a bummer
for Donna and B it would probably
require an entire season to do I mean I
don't know man I I think that I don't
want to have the most unbelievable
recency bias but that could climb to
being one of my absolute favorite
episodes honestly yeah which is like
really gratifying for a special because
like again it's a commemorative thing
and stuff but again some specials are
better than others and I like limited
characters
uh contain [__] like I I I'm just a big
fan of that and stuff that that thrives
on mood and that gets you really kind of
wondering and disconcerted and I love
that this I also appreciate when things
get a little demented because it doesn't
happen a whole lot and this definitely
got a little demented in a way that I I
like cuz cuz yeah especially when
they're first introducing like the the
distorted arms and Limbs and stuff it's
just so it's like kooky but it's not
playing it like that overtly funny it's
just like it it is it's it kind of is
summed up by the thing she says at the
end uh you know why is Mrs Bean funny it
just is you know even though it's
technically the wrong Donna's answer but
you know like it but she was
99.9% Donna at that point yeah and so
like it is that it kind of nicely
mirrors that of of like these things are
kind of like quirky and funny but also
they're not playing it that way they
just are you know absolutely yeah I'm
just checking something out
terrific terrific
episode
oh all right we got it all right so good
we are so good
um
I'm I'm
complete all righty guys well thank you
so much appreciate the fress of this
review um and but uh subscribe leave a
like thank you to Shopify for sponsoring
be sure to subscribe click the
notification Bell for reaction next
episode but hey before we clock out got
to shout out some special
patrons time to shout out our super
sexies who are at our $10 T I'll get a
quick little shout out here so we have
utilized what I call the the future of
the real Rejects and how we have formed
all of our opinions via chat gbt we've
been doing this since before this
program even existed so I have asked
chat gbt to um give a quick shout out of
what Santa would give each of them for
Christmas let's see we're going to react
to it in real time to see what Santa is
going to give to them let's find
out Jack Forest this Christmas Santa's
bringing Jack forest's very own magical
forest Adventure reminiscent of the
Enchanted Woods in the polo Express full
of wonder and excitement aren't you
special beautiful Jack forest namari for
namari Santa has crafted a journey akin
to the nut cracker where each twist and
turn in their story reveals a world of
Fantastical Delights and dreamy wonders
oh my God I'd love to have my nuts
cracked yes Mike Joyce is getting a
special Miracle on 34th Street huhuh
Experience from Santa where his
unwavering belief in the magic of
Christmas brings joy to all around him
nice Santa's a perve AI gusai great name
AI gai's Christmas gift is a chis A
Christmas Carol Adventure where he's
Guided by spirits of Christmas unveiling
the true meaning of the season in a
Journey Through Time well a lot of
Christian allegories in the Aller Baby
Ryan Smith will find himself in a home
alone style Escapade wow what a great
gift from Santa he's creating a whole
escape room for you filled with
ingenious traps and clever tricks
defending the joy of Christmas with wit
and laughter H sand is I got a cruel
cruel Little Spirit here sense of humor
Kevin Meek Kevin Meek's holiday season
is set to resemble elf where his
boundless enthusiasm and Christmas
spirit brings lofter and joy to every te
me and uh you're our you're our buddy
you're just going to have enthusiasm in
a Christmas spirit that's your gift
you're just going to be a guy who likes
Christmas here's your gift you're in a
good mood you got a nice green Smock you
know Adrien Tim's Santa sending him on a
holiday in inspired musical Journey
filled with song dance and the Timeless
beauty of classic Christmas Melodies I
kind of feel like Santa's playing
favoritism here I'm not going to lie
it's true it's true Santa well you know
you gota be you gota be nice NV deep
sidu navdeep suu's Christmas Tale is
akin to its wonderful life where the
true richness of life is revealed
through the love and connections you
share seriously sometimes he's like
you're in a good mood and uh here's a
little hey you're connecting with people
at Christmas your gift is a revelation
yes real nagas will experience a jingle
all the way Adventure full of fun and
fervor as he sets out on a hilarious
quest to find the most sought after
Christmas gift Turbo
Man well good luck cuz they don't
actually produce those in stores n
tickled me Heather gear Heather Gear's
festive season is like a scene from
White
Christmas filled with cozy snowy moments
and the warmth of classic holiday cheer
that's just describing like celebrating
a holiday at all going to break in and
redesign your whole home yeah jonos
Christmas gift is a Love Actually
experience where every corner of his
life intertwines in a beautiful tapestry
of Love friendship and festive Joy okay
so Santa's going to hold stand outside
and hold out a sign a couple signs for
you yeah to me you are naughty uh Ian
Simon will uh relive the magic of a
Christmas story where his childhood
dreams and holiday wishes come to life
in the most heartwarming and humorous
ways until you shoot your eye out kid
and then you got to go to the hospital
and experience the terror of the
American Health System s High Glover
Santa has prepared a Frosty the Snowman
tale where his joy and laughter bring to
life a jolly happy soul during the
festive season again you're just going
to be in a good mood just with a snowman
friend snowman friend congratulations on
Glover you win hey Kayla the king though
uh your holiday Adventure mirrors the
Santa Claus where a series of unexpected
events lead you to discover the true
essence of Christmas spirit and joy and
then eventually you have to use the
Escape Clause wow Chachi DT is just
[__] you know it's just referencing
Kevin figy just been like your Christmas
is going to be let me tell you what it
is it's going to be something to look
forward to and full of a lot of cheer
once you're done using your gift there's
something on the bottom of it that's
going to get you really excited for next
Christmas Olivier Hamlin's Christmas
story is like Scrooge where he's going
to ReDiscover the joy and warmth of the
holiday season in a modern day Twist on
a classic tale you're the most Bill
Murray of all the patrons
this doesn't even make sense Scrooged
all righty uh you know Allan Ling's
Christmas experience is akin to National
Lampoons Christmas vacation you filthy
animal uh filled with humorous mishaps
and a heartwarming conclusion about
family and glove oh okay good sounds
like it's going to actually be a toxic
Christmas it is and there's going to be
poop Kiera your holiday season takes a
magical turn like in the Grinch where
the true meaning of of Christmas blooms
in your heart you're going to grow a
second heart turning every moment into a
joyous celebration and then you'll be
put in some kind of Museum and studied
Juan Longoria check it out dude your
festive tale is it Christmas with the
cranks Escapade where your plan to skip
Christmas leads to unexpected and
heartwarming Revelations about
community and joy I figured it out what
Santa's doing for everyone this year is
throwing
into a story of
self-discovery every Christmas Story the
most requisite Christmas feelings and
Aesthetics watch let's see if this okay
we haven't we don't know maybe it's
different for Cliff Rodriguez Cliff
rodrig you're going to find yourself in
a Santa Claus Is Coming a town scenario
where your actions will remind everyone
about the spirit of giving and the magic
of Christmas dude okay yeah this is just
remixing all of the tenants of like how
you're supposed to feel and act on
Christmas and then naming a movie well I
can guarantee you that go Nation watch
watch it's going to be very different oh
yeah totally I mean for go Nation get
this Santa has a Rudolph the rednose
reindeer Adventure be very it's going to
be very Rudolph inspired definitely
because check this out when uh being
unique leads to an extraordinary
Christmas that lights up the world Wok
wow W so unlike everyone else you were
going to have a an adventure tailor to
your
specific emotional experience needs on a
global scale that will make you realize
the true meaning of Christmas on a
global so you're the only one who's
going to get that definitely and Lorenzo
Baxter okay get ready cuz yours is going
to be very different from everyone
else's your Christmas story is going to
be inspired by A Charlie Brown Christmas
where Simplicity and heartfelt moments
reveal the true beauty of the season and
then you recite scripture I kind of feel
like this Santa this m s is a bit of a a
cheat here m s is running out of
insiration just take a dear off
differently saying check this out though
differently saying you're going to break
the mold because your festive journey is
like Frosty Returns a sequel where your
wit and charm are going to bring a new
wave of stuff happening on screen that's
right a new wave of Christmas magic and
Unforgettable fun wow okay everyone else
is going to be like forgettable and not
filled with with magic well Marco tons
still see what I love about what Santa
is doing is they list a movie a very
specific movie with a very specific
character that it makes me think it's
going to be something more Akin tailored
to that movie and
character but they do something better
cuz like watch you're going to get this
holiday season it's going to unfold
Marco tun still like a Muppet Christmas
Carol but unlike everyone else familiar
faces and joyous songs are going to make
for a heartwarming and entertaining
Christmas my God nuts I've never even
seen up at Christmas Carol but I feel
like I have now yeah yeah dude it would
simply faded for your Christmas
experience you're going to do a deck the
hall Style Christmas where bright lights
and friendly rivalry ignite the true
Spirit of the holidays in a shocking
Twist of events friendly rivalry that's
a that's that's an oxymoron any rival is
a a threat to your success
um but SJ 994 your Christmas is going to
be like the Night Before Christmas I'm
assuming or the night before the night
before with Joseph Gordon Lev and
Michael Shannon that's the one you want
filled with unexpected adventures and
hilarious escapades that lead to
memorable and cherished holiday moments
again vager is the key and that's why
people are threatened by what chat gbt
can do yeah
absolutely I just want one of these
where you're not going to remember
Justin Martin could be the one holiday
story for you is it in to Arthur
Christmas underrated Christmas movie
watch it if you haven't where Hightech
holiday operations and a heart of gold
ensure every Christmas wish is fulfilled
not necessarily by your doing just it
will happen in your adventure okay well
okay well well you know that this has to
be unique cuz this is for Rosie batty
Darth toota Order 66 you're Christmas
gift is a Star Wars Star Wars holiday
special experience where you're going to
blend your love for the G far far away
with the festive Spirit of the Season
yeah spend all your freaking time on Kik
it's hanging out in chew house the best
thing you want is a reference to the
Star Wars holiday special hey that's the
cliff back what what's going the
computer's melting down but Colin you're
GNA save Christmas for us because your
tal is inspired by Fred claws where uh
your unique approach to the holidays
brings Jo uh laughter
joy and something we haven't heard those
are new but this is also new a fresh
perspective on kisma spirit I don't
think any of the other ones have
contained those elements this is really
fleshing out the holidays it's crazy
it's I no Christmas could be so many
things I didn't know they could get more
generic but somehow this is like the
deeper the list goes the eventually the
last person just going to be like you're
going to have a good time on Christmas
next time we should do eight nights of
Hanukkah per person and see if it can
come up with that many exponential
scenarios oh we got this John Philip J
Smith Jr your holiday Adventure is going
to be uh specifically tailored to the
film The Family Stone good now based off
of that film you the complexities of
your family Dynamics guess what's going
to happen it's going to lead to a deeper
understanding and appreciation of Love
impossible it's not possible I don't buy
it that this Christmas that'd be a big
miracle if ever there was J Smith okay
this you know Miracles all right Jen
Smith's Christmas is like the holiday
where a change of scenery and some Han
Zimmer music leads to heartwarming
discoveries about love happiness and the
magic of the festive season and you're
going to spend some time with Jack Black
you know we'll get ready for some a huge
huge fireworks on our final one today
yeah Melanie Melanie LeBlanc okay oh wow
Four Christmases four different stories
within one movie asy as ree Witherspoon
and Vince Von uh who often avoid their
family trying to knock it all out in one
day with a bunch of very you know
distinct characters and family Dynamics
per family true that let's see what they
come up with uh Melanie Leong's festive
story unfolds like like movie The Four
Christmases which I just laid out for
you what happens all four of we n ating
holiday celebration reveals the joy
chaos chaos and love we got some chaos
that Define the Christmas
spirit so everyone is going to discover
uh what the real meaning of Christmas is
all about which is getting along and
being nice celebrate feel some joy and
hey maybe there might be a little bit of
contrast dysfunction or whatever but
everyone's going to feel festive I think
chbt overd delivered PT is a church
right now getting ready for the Lord to
be
born guys thank you for being here and
uh and stay tuned for the next round of
amazing Christmas stories each more
unlikely than the
last we love
you